- [Instructor] We're told that glucose,
C6H12O6, reacts with oxygen
to give carbon dioxide and water.
What mass of oxygen, in grams,
is required for complete reaction
of 25.0 grams of glucose?
What masses of carbon dioxide and water,
in grams, are formed?
So, pause this video and see
if you can have a go at this
and then we'll work through this together.
All right, now first let's
just set up the reaction.
So, this is going to be,
we have glucose, so that is C6H12O6,
is going to react with oxygen.
Now, oxygen in its molecular
form is going to be O2.
And what it gives is
carbon dioxide and water.
Plus water.
Now the next question is are we balanced.
Do we have a conservation of mass here?
And let's just go element by element.
So first let's focus on the carbons.
So, we have six carbons
on the left-hand side of this reaction.
How many carbons do we have
on the right-hand side?
Well, right now we only have one carbon
in this carbon dioxide molecule.
So if we want the carbons to be conserved
we need to have six carbons on
the right-hand side as well.
So let me see what'll happen
when I throw a six there.
So now my carbons are balanced:
six on the left, six on the right.
Now let's look at the other elements.
So on the left-hand side I
have 12 hydrogens in total.
On the right-hand side I
only have two hydrogens.
So if I want to balance that
I could multiply the water molecule.
Instead of just one
here, I could have six,
and now this would be 12 hydrogen atoms
so both the carbons and the
hydrogens are now balanced.
By putting that six there I
haven't messed with the carbons.
And now last, but not least,
let's think about the oxygens here.
So on the left, we have six oxygens there
and then another two oxygens there.
So that's a total of eight oxygens.
And on the right, I have
six times two, I have 12
plus another six oxygens.
So I have 18 oxygens
on the right-hand side,
and I only have eight oxygens
on the left-hand side.
So I have to increase
the number of oxygens
on the left-hand side.
So let's see.
This six you can imagine
matches up with this six.
So if I could somehow
make this into 12 oxygens,
I'll be good.
So the best way to make
this into 12 oxygens
is to multiply this by
six, so let me do that.
So if I put a six right over
here, I think I'm all balanced.
I have six carbons on both sides,
I have 12 hydrogens on both sides,
and it looks like I have
18 oxygens on both sides.
So I'm a fully balanced equation here.
So let me get a periodic table of elements
and I only need to think about
carbon, hydrogen, and oxygen.
So for the sake of space, let
me scroll down a little bit.
I just need to look at
this stuff over here.
And so, let's first,
let's see hydrogen's right up here.
And we can see in this
periodic table of elements,
it gives the average atomic mass,
but you can also view that number
1.008, as its molar mass.
So it's 1.008 grams per mole of hydrogen.
Now we can move on to carbon.
Carbon is 12.01, 12.01
grams per mole of carbon.
And then last but not
least, oxygen over here.
That is 16.00 grams per mole of oxygen.
And now we can use that information.
I can now remove our
periodic table of elements.
We can use this information to figure out
the molar masses of
each of these molecules.
So for example, glucose right over here,
if we're talking about C6H12O6,
how many grams per mole
is that going to be?
How many grams is a mole
of glucose going to be?
Well, it's six carbons, 12
hydrogens, and six oxygens.
So one way to think about is going to be
six times this, so it's going to be
six times 12.01
plus we have 12 times 1.008
plus six times 16.00,
and then this is going
to be grams per mole.
And this is going to
be equal to, let's see,
72.06 plus 12.096
plus six times 16 is 96.00.
Of course all of this
is in grams per mole.
And so this is going to
be equal to, let's see,
72 plus 12 is 84
plus 96 is 180,
180 point, and let's see,
we have 60 thousandths
plus 96 thousandths,
which would be 156 thousandths,
so 156 thousandths grams per mole.
Let me make sure I got the
significant figures right.
The six, the 12 and six are pure numbers,
so I'm still good with this.
And then when I add
these numbers together,
I need to round to as
much precision as I have
in the least one.
So here I go up to the hundredths,
up to the hundredths,
up to the thousandths.
So I need to round this,
actually, to the hundredths place.
So this is going to be 180.16
grams per mole of glucose.
And now let's think about
the other molecules.
If we think about oxygen,
I'll do that over here to save space,
oxygen, that's pretty straightforward.
A molecular oxygen molecule
just has two oxygen atoms,
so it's going to be two times this,
so it's going to be 32.00 grams per mole.
And then carbon dioxide.
Carbon dioxide is going to be,
it's two oxygens plus one carbon.
So it's going to be this plus one carbon,
so that's this plus 12.01,
so that's 44.01 grams per mole.
And then last but not
least we have the water.
And so, H2O.
This is going to be two hydrogens,
so that's two times 1.008,
so that's 2.016 plus an oxygen.
So that's going to be 2.016 plus 16
is going to be 18.016.
Once again, we only go to
the hundredths place here,
so I'm going to round to
the hundredths place here.
So 18.02 grams per mole.
Now the next step is to think about,
all right we're reacting
with 25 grams of glucose.
How many moles of glucose is that?
So we have 25.0,
25.0 grams of glucose.
And we want to turn this
into moles of glucose.
And we know the molar mass
is 180.16 grams per mole,
or we could multiply and say that this is
for every one mole, per
mole, it is 180.16 grams.
All I did is take the
reciprocal of this over here.
And notice, the grams
will cancel with the grams
and I'll be left with moles of glucose.
That's going to be equal to 25.0
divided by 180.16 moles of glucose.
25 divided by 180.16 is equal to this.
And let's see, I have
three significant figures
divided by five significant figures.
So I'm going to round to
three significant figures.
So 0.139.
So this is approximately equal
to 0.139 mole of glucose.
Now, they say the first question is
what mass of oxygen is required
for a complete reaction of this.
Well, for every mole of glucose we need
six moles of molecular oxygen.
And so, we're going to need,
let me just multiply that times six.
So times six is equal to that.
And remember, I had three
significant figures.
So, 0.833.
So we're going to need
0.833 moles of molecular oxygen.
And then I just multiply that
times the molar mass of molecular oxygen.
So, times 32.00 grams per
mole of molecular oxygen.
0.833 times 32 is equal to that.
If you go three significant figures,
it's 26.7.
26.7 grams of oxygen, of molecular oxygen.
And so we've answered the
first part of the question.
What mass of oxygen is
required for complete reaction?
So, that's this right over here.
And then the next question is what masses
of carbon dioxide and
water in grams are formed.
Remember, for every one mole of glucose,
we needed six moles of molecular oxygen
and we produce six moles of carbon dioxide
and we produce six moles of water.
So this is the number of moles of glucose
we input into the reaction.
Six times that was this.
So this is actually
also the number of moles
of carbon dioxide or water
that we're going to produce.
So, if we take our original 0.833 mole
of carbon dioxide and I multiply that
times carbon dioxide's molar mass,
44.01 grams per mole,
this is going to be
approximately equal to,
.833 times 44.01
is equal to three significant figures,
36.7 grams.
36.7 grams of carbon dioxide.
And once again, you can see
that the moles cancel with the moles,
just as they did before, to
give us grams of carbon dioxide.
And then last but not least,
we can do that with the water.
0.833 mole of H2O times its molar mass,
times 18.02 grams per mole of water
is going to give us approximately
.833 times 18.02, gives us,
three significant figures
is going to be 15.0.
15.0 grams of water.
And once again, those moles canceled out
to give us the right units.
And we're done, which is pretty cool.
This is really useful in chemistry
to be able to understand,
based on a balanced chemical equation,
hey, if I have a certain
mass of one of the inputs,
one of the things that
are one of the reactants,
how much do I need of the other?
And then how much mass of the products
am I actually going to produce?
All of which we just figured out.